a toulouse je les vois et c'est vrai
qu'on a fait une petite surprise à
quelqu'un ah oui on a fait le voeu des
surprises à votre père ça c'était énorme
je me suis caché en fait dans la maison
de leur père il faut savoir juste en
prenant même si je peux me permettre
ainsi les animaux pris un but important
emprunt de notre père est un grand fan
de télé un grand fan de toi même avant
qu'on devienne connu avant qu'on arrive
dans ses émissions il est très fine
crème du coup on a gardé avec lui tout
le temps ouais du coup on a pensé une
surprise pour lui était venue à toulouse
exprès pour ça pour ça aussi à l'époque
je venais en fait
regardez ils sont tranquillement dans le
patio été choqués là du coup on est dans
notre ancienne maison c'est là où tout a
commencé vraiment si cela se laver son
honneur lundi
quand vous faites pas de la musique
qu'est ce que vous faites et goffi vous
regarde la télé en fait à banksy qui
démarre la carrière on regardait
beaucoup beaucoup la télé vous en équipe
et je regardais des cons et début oui et
voir vous en pensez quoi le cirena mais
la mission est l' idée de l'émission
elle est bien mais c'est dommage que ce
soit lui quoi les sénateurs ce qu'il
aime peloux et une toujours les mêmes
blagues c'est fatigant pas il me fait
pas rire
non au début un petit peu mais là c'est
fini
il soulève y est à moi je dire ce serait
quoi c'est qui produit ce qu'ils savent
à plein d'options écart est l'animation
on se répand c'est la bonne solution
ouais bon va très bien j'ai lu dire là
je pense vraiment que c'est la meilleure
solution
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je croyais que c'était à moi il est beau
désolé maman c'est extra pas pouvoir
défendre mes questions je parlerais
d'avancée dans ses bras avec une embolie
pendant mes son canapé je me rêvais de
mon livre il m'a laissé veillée devant
les crimes que j'aimais bien
il m'engage jamais le pire est-il
derrière celle là c'est pour nos pères
nos braves et ceux des dix jeunes eux
mêmes sans même parler on sait que
regrette le qui sont pas passées je
citais papa tu sais que t'es pas
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr du djembé et les bons du
fonds s'est invitée sur l'émission tu
sors ton album
bah oui serait obligé glace confère un
traîneau peu après cette séquence là
tout va si bien
la normale en émission et je crois qu'il
arrive la vie une très grosse tenue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
clément
merci bush alors je lui avais conseillé
la tenue et je voudrais m'excuser auprès
de fabian parce qu'en fait je vous dis
rire est au départ ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il dit qu'il m'aime beaucoup
etc
mais je crois que c'est toi qui lui dit
moi je vais dit non tu vas dire lambert
parce que c'est pas expliqué dans
l'année va forcément perdre il expliqué
pour preuve il a fait tellement de peine
ou été tellement pas bien il aimait pas
dire du mal de toi me disait tu es sourd
ils m'ont dit il mon dit le pour les
faire une blague parlement de lui mais
là ils me l'ont pas mis cependant si la
lame et en plus je savais pas que
j'étais là mais c'est ce que j'ai dit
non mais t'inquiète pas tu te sens tu te
je t'aime quand même on va bien et avec
qui ne savent pas en fait notre notre
père on le produit son album c'est un
peu le monde à l'envers c'est votre
enfant qui ne savent pas qui va sortir
en l'annonçant total exclut ici le 25
oct rien n'est pas une pure altitude
je compte sur vous et le musicien un
quota franchement j'en profite d'être à
l'antenne pour te remercier parce que je
sais que tu es hyper crier tout est
descendu et ça m'a vraiment beaucoup de
toucher devant la folie vous le savez à
excellent musicien si vous fumez à la
hâte
[Applaudissements]
attendent de venir avec stéphane est en
fait moi je croyais que c'était une
voilà un truc comme ça en fait le gars
il se déplace toujours là mais c'est un
truc de ouf ça veut dire je ne peux pas
aimer le papa du bien c'est parti vas-y
aussi c'est l'histoire d'un amour
éternel et banale qui apporte chaque
jour
nous le vîmes
[Musique]
avec de la rue
ansa
[Musique]
c'est l'eau
on se dit adieu
[Musique]
avec les soirées danois se
mon
et le matin
merveilleux
peu
janota masse a mis la relation l alma
sont notés ngo solera si jeanne
offriront vérité est ce que dit on me
sauf qu'elle était parsemé soufflé de
bras
[Musique]
sur les fruits c'est la re-so d'avenir
city à l'honneur par harri olli qui ya
trouvé son yacht fera l calories
mirlinda ma vie et la mort il abat sur
rihanna select revient à confondre à y
aura 13
ils sont prêts
à part
m
[Musique]
highco hui à manosque où
si toi vos jeux vos idées
dans l'histoire c'est l'histoire des
rameaux jsm joue la même violence
mais naïve c'est la seule son niveau
[Musique]
il n'oubliera jamais
un nouveau village
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons eu
non à dieu
abonnés le papa de boulogne qui est avec
nous s'est amusé à braquer un si gros et
micky chili bravo draconis mois pour lui
exceptionnel
merci le shérif merci à vous fais un
truc je reste là et c'est normal
les galères on a vu aussi mon père
galéré est ce que vous racontez toute
son histoire
est-ce qu'on peut guider mon père y sait
pas s'il doit respirer par me guider ma
lancée alors là alors que je fais tu as
un peu tu vas jusqu'à la prochaine pub
oui alors il va permettre à lui est un
vrai clip sur mamy qui allait tout le
temps non mais je t'écoute est passé
d'un sexy mois
c'est mon père aulas on organise pour
l'organisatrice l'eau
allez ont été volés isabelle isabelle il
va venir vous invitez c'est pas c'est
pas comme ça vous êtes une princesse
portait ses beaux vers l'arène de dazhou
pêcheries non vous allez l'invité je
vais le faire comme ont offert un jeune
type d'accord voilà où là il va t'offrir
de l'avion ok bah si cyril civile oui
c'est comme ça on la regarde de loin aux
faits
[Applaudissements]
m
seniors l'an
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alan merci céréales franchement je pense
qu'on va faire des très grandes marques
arrosoir merci d'un coup
[Applaudissements]
j'ai déjà pas bien non non et qui ont
regardé moi non mais oui encore en tant
que porte si c'est en tant que génial je
le trouve magnifique
honnêtement les nazis merci merci
toutefois il a dit m'a dit n'importe
quoi
très très grave
c'est un grand fan de télé mon père
salah je sais ça vraiment il est une
chose et j'ai beaucoup regardé la télé
mais après limoux la mémoire non